we're gonna have I think 10 or 11 people
and we'll just hear their views and well
and where do I sit in the corner I know
you invite certain watch would be next
room behind that whatever room there's
nothing there's a mirror no this side it
looks like a mirror but on the other
side you can see and hear them they
won't be able to see or hear you know
Wow
give a little yank you know Elaine
please don't do that I better just have
a seat anywhere look at this guy
these are real American well there we go
hi honey
look at that perfect lace I think
everybody for being here today my name
is Jason the moderator looks like a
beaver let's go around the room and have
everybody say your name minutes George
my name is Greg hey what's your name
Eddie reigns Yoda Yoda in love I think I
am alright let's just start off with
sort of a general question can they hear
us no they can't hear us if we want to
talk to Jason we just talking to this
microphone what do you think are the
most important issues facing America
middle of America has been decimated and
it's found that they were brought back
into consideration the boring who have
any snacks or anything what change isn't
happening because a different lock I
think the biggest issue is our health
failing us the Gilda's merits or okay a
ring around her finger listen I'll tell
you what I told Billy Bush no don't you
all know airing that I've moved I know
like I'm a bitch anyway I can tell
myself any part of the biggest issues we
see today is the economy
I know it sorry sir no you have to rip
it off I told you you're supposed to rip
it off look another time light I got
another car quickly I'm rigid real and
just as a general question and we need a
spy show of hands do you feel that the
country is on the right track
only three I've sort of been on your
percentage at wrong track
one chair your animal of normal jerks
what are you doing why ain't the same
things like President Trump is so great
it's my job to be neutral I can't be
arrested you have you had a fruit
roll-up Kimba fruit nut Montana so take
that it all you're gonna do don't do
that no no this is this is sort of a no
no no no no don't kiss
don't kiss no no don't you're gonna kiss
I can't watch I can't watch
I can't watch I can't watch I can't
watch don't no don't don't
what's happening what's happening did
you that's a kiss of death I understand
man oh God yeah I have some real
question okay um let me shift gears a
little bit
do you think that he has the potential
to become a great president that's
potential best quality worst quality
what are you doing just the best quality
Jason I want you to turn the women and
say we need to do the rest of this
topless sir if you can't do that it's
shirts and skins and all the women of
the skin sir no Jason please we all got
to see it don't look at this mirror do
not look at this mirror don't say no
there may be so sorry chase I am the
President of the United States and we're
just having a tiny hair Jason just need
a bunch of nuts and all the money amount
ain't no particular making it on if I
get out of here Jason
daddy you Jason I should never get you I
should have never gets you willing home
goes all in the way I will go and stay
and I will go in you're gone
sorry about that that was a Jason had to
had to go this is how you doing okay I'm
gonna get the right answers just overall
a question about the president is how
great of a job is he doing on a scale of
7 to 11 7 to 11
I'm gonna say 10 for president Truong
and 11 for president so Pence is doing
better than Trump black no no that's not
true that's a perfect answer that's grow
and then that still michael value doing
she said I was doing an 11 and that you
are doing it to that and bill agreed
bill also said 11 to 10 what a
disappointing bunch of people and I want
you all to leave who didn't agree with
me now get up and leave get out
George get out of here for real get out
Craig and shut the door back to the
server who here was the Donald J Trump
he's the greatest president to ever work
[Music]
100% on for women
to that and of the son
screw you Gallup spur you clean approval